[Music]
hi good evening everyone thank you so
much for joining me tonight and taking
your saturday night to come and listen
to me talk about whiteness in my podcast
we need to talk about whiteness
my name is dr mariam frasswa i'm a
journalist and a documentary filmmaker
i've also got an academic background
looking at particularly at postcolonial
societies and movements anti-colonial
movements i've phd from oxford looking
specifically at those areas in
2019 i set up the podcast we need to
talk about whiteness
to engage in conversations around racism
but with a focus on whiteness and i
guess maybe the first question that
always comes up is one that i pose to
all of my guests
so we're now episode 19 which was just
released this week um what is whiteness
is one of the questions i asked and why
did i want to ask that question well
partly because it seemed to me that um
the
focus of anti-racism seem to be
placing the onus on
the victims of racism by people of color
those who are experiencing racism to
deal with a problem that was rooted in
ideologies and structures of power that
had been developed principally by
what we would call white people
europeans
um and subsequently um americans and
i think i should point out that just as
whiteness is a construct just as race is
a construct whiteness is a construct it
emerges from the world of critical race
studies in america which if you're
following the news you will have
gathered has a fairly bad rep when it
comes to uh the current government's
view of what should be taught um
why does it have a bad rep i think it's
probably because there's a certain
resistance still in this country to
recognizing or acknowledging forms of
systemic racism
um i think we'll touch on a lot of the
points uh in in the talk now but overall
what i would say is that the study
or the the investigation of whiteness i
launched in with the podcast was very
much about trying to understand the
structure underpinning racism where does
racism come from where does the belief
firstly in the concept of races which
does not exist race races are constructs
although racism is very real so we all
have different ethnicities but they
don't necessarily have implications um
certainly not hierarchical ones in terms
of human value so where did that concept
come from and what kind of impact has it
continued to have um in our societies um
until the modern day so that's what the
podcast set out to do and in each
episode my objective was to engage with
um a particular um individual um you
know everyone from film directors to
comedians via academics journalists
fashion designers
all of whom had a particular have a
particular take on this conversation
around whiteness
and in particular as i said one of my
first questions to them is always what
is
whiteness now um so obviously or maybe
not obviously um i am racialized as
white i am half french half irish um but
i also happen to be muslim and for most
of my adult life i wore a head scarf
from the age of 21
and during the period in which i started
to
wear
dress that would identify me as muslim i
suddenly awoke to the reality that there
were two tears in our society or at
least two tears there was the tear of um
what i would like to call white
innocence which was the world that i um
existed in prior to that in which uh my
presence in a space was unquestioned my
perspectives always deemed important um
my value
um
virtually always recognized although
arguably between men and women there are
differences there and able-bodied and
disabled also um
and i guess
what i really started to realize was
that once i started to be identified as
non-white or off-white or not part of
the white majority which is
how people started to perceive me once i
was wearing
clothes that identified me as a muslim i
then started to also be treated
differently in different spheres of my
life and this would include things like
being followed around
a shop that i had been shopping in for
many years and never ever had that
experience prior to that it was undue
hostility from strangers in a way that
sometimes felt surprising and um
unreasonable and in many ways
unnecessary relative to
uh whatever the situation was um all the
way through obviously to instances of
actual uh verbal uh abuse um
uh you know through to various forms of
threats so it was a bit of a wake-up
call to
the experience um
of racism which you know i'd heard
obviously about second-hand from a lot
of my friends but i suddenly realized
that actually um these aren't uh sort of
individual
instances um it's almost like stepping
through the looking glass
into a world in which
your
presence your existence is
has a has a question mark over it and
you have to justify
every aspect of it and i know that might
not seem
um intuitively
true to many people who haven't
experienced it but that certainly
was my experience for many many years
um
and so that was one of the motivations
really it was uh it continues to be a
motivation because till this day i
consider the fact that um
when i talk about um my views my
identity my beliefs that i still have to
um
moderate or
be be attentive to how i talk about my
faith for example um because a lot of
people will not deem it
acceptable for me to speak
from a muslim subjectivity in particular
conversation so yesterday to give you a
concrete example i was doing a panel on
feminism and talking about whiteness in
feminism and what that looks like and to
me it was the experience of never really
being able to enter that space and speak
as a muslim
who's also a feminist and having to
actually justify my presence in that
group as a muslim so why you know i'd
have to essentially answer two
white women in the group who considered
themselves judge and jury of what
constitutes feminism
as to
whether i was a veritable feminist so
back to the podcast the podcast started
out really from uh understanding through
that personal experience but also in
recent years becoming increasingly aware
that um
friends um colleagues were becoming very
uh frustrated with a conversation on
anti-racism which as i said continued to
place the onus on uh those who were if
you're going to talk structurally
speaking um not those really uh in in
charge of creating the unequal power
relations um so it seemed like it's a
white problem created by white people
and therefore probably needs white
people to address um and find a solution
um
james baldwin famously said what white
people have to do is to try and find
find out in their own hearts why it was
necessary to have a
n-word in the first place because i'm
not a n-word i'm a man but if you think
i'm an n-word it means you need it
and i think
quotes like his quotes like tony
morrison's who says the belief in
whiteness is a category of specialness
covers up deep-seated insecurity and
doubt what are you without racism she
asks are you any good are you still
strong are you still smart do you even
like yourself
and so these were um
sections i'd read in in books that would
really make me think okay
there is such a thing as whiteness i've
experienced my version of it um and yet
we don't really seem to be discussing it
why do we not talk about whiteness why
do we always focus on
uh racism which is the manifestation of
whiteness and not whiteness which i
regard as the structure from which uh
racism flows the best description i
actually found of whiteness was uh one
author who spoke about um whiteness
being like that uncle that crazy uncle
that we all have in the attic um or in
the family who basically has all this
accumulated um
wealth who's a kind of nasty piece of
work and um we don't particularly like
him and and we certainly um don't want
to be like him but we vaguely tolerate
him and we look forward to inheriting um
the wealth that he passes down when he
dies
so for me that's a really good
representation of how i perceive
whiteness and therefore the role that i
see
um people who are racialized as white
needing to take in addressing the
problem of racism
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas